in the corridors of Brussels a power
struggle is underway that could change
the course of Europe a battle between
more or less Europe is centered around
one man jean-claude juncker a
pro-european from the old guard however
many argue that the head of the
Commission should be at the vanguard of
a reformed Europe the socialists and
Democrats made clear their support would
be conditional yonka has to change some
of his policies this is a condition
where when we support him on the other
hand we have to recognize that
anti-austerity vote has not been as
strong and as clear as we would like to
wish as a result of the European
elections center right candidate jonker
has a claim to the presidency of the
Commission but some EU leaders have
suggested other less Federalists names
we put on the table birthday in case
Lawson interscope lo Duca economy the
snitch first and advisor Canada and keep
thinking tell dizzy crafting rod it is
destructor d Canada at wyndham in
Ferguson diras que ondas venir open an a
in Stretton le creuset came the British
conservatives are threatening to use
their trump card a brexit to counter
yonkers candidacy in order to placate
the wishes of the UK Brussels may have
to bargain hard to keep them on board
this has revived the idea of the
two-speed Europe with a eurozone core
and an outer circle less tied to
Brussels the British Conservative
nominee for the presidency of the
parliaments IE Kareem has struck a more
conciliatory note if it is the ultimate
decision that it should be mr. Juncker
then we need to ensure that there is a
counterbalance in terms of the other
positions that exist so that people who
are not of the mind that it should be
mr. Juncker do not find themselves
pushed to the fringes of Europe what
started as an exercise in democracy has
descended into a political battle the
next ten days will decide whether Europe
strikes the right balance